The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[FELICE FRANKEL] So I'm sitting
here in Kim Vandiver's office.
And actually, Kim was
the very first person who
got what I was trying to do.
I knocked on his
door, basically.
Isn't that right?
Basically knocked on your
door and said, "can I
please come here and
make science pictures?"
This was in 1994.
You were the director of
the new Edgerton Center
that just formed.
And you said sure,
let's give it a shot.
And I just started making
more science pictures.
And that kind of grew into
something more wonderful
here at MIT.
So thanks, Kim, for
giving us some time.
We're really eager to
see this little story
about Doc, and certainly
about the pictures
that he made, what he's known
for, and some of your pictures,
too.
It would be fun to tell
a bit of a story for us.
[KIM VANDIVER] Thank you.
I'm really looking forward
to talking with you.
It should be a lot of fun.
[FF] You bet.
So what drew me to
the Edgerton Center
is that people knew about it.
And that's really where very
exciting photography of science
was taking place.
And so it was a natural place
for me to at least start.
[KV] Right.
It had the Doc Edgerton history,
and lots of famous photographs.
And she didn't
know me from Adam.
Right?
I was just the director of the
Edgerton Center at the time.
[FF] What gave me
the impetus was
that I had been starting playing
around at Harvard with George
Whitsides' work.
And I did, in fact, have
a very small portfolio
of some pictures that I
made in a science lab.
And so I had something to show.
It wasn't that I just
came in and said, hire me.
[KV] Right.
You had the Whitesides'
pictures at the time.
[FF] I had the
Whitesides' pictures.
And I think I might have
had a cover at that point.
[KV] I think you did.
You had the cover
of the liquids on
the hydrophobic and
hydrophilic surfaces.
[FF] You remember?
[KV] Absolutely.
[FF] Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
But still, I'll be
forever indebted to Kim
for opening up the doors.
That's basically
what you did for me.
[KV] That's what
we intended to do.
That's what the Edgerton
Center was supposed to be for.
So Doc first published
his photographs in a book
in the 1930's.
And the first book was edited
by Jim Kelly, who, at that time,
was the director of
Technology Review.
And he later became
the president of MIT.
[FF] Killian.
OK.
There we go.
I know that name somewhere.
[KV] And so Killian--
and if you had
noticed, even this
book is-- this one
was published in the late '70s.
And again, it's still
Edgerton and Killian.
[FF] Interesting.
[KV] So Killian edited the
first three books with Doc.
[FF] And where do you come in?
[KV] Well, where I came in
was I was a grad student
here for a year in 1968.
And when you come here to MIT in
the '60s, you heard about Doc.
He was a phenomenon at MIT.
But then I left and went
those two years in the Army,
and I took up
photography as a hobby
and developed my own--
built in Trang, Vietnam
in 1970, a darkroom that anybody
could use, but then developed
my own color slides
while I was there.
[FF] Kodachrome or E6?
[KV] No.
The only thing--
[FF] That couldn't
have been Kodachrome.
[KV] No.
I think it was-- the only one
that you could get the process
for, I think, was Ectochrome.
[FF] Which is E6.
[KV] Yeah.
And so built this photo lab on
my spare time in Trang, Vietnam
in 1970 and taught myself
to develop color film, which
is a painful process.
[FF] Awful.
[KV] Temperature
controls and all of that.
So then I show up back at
MIT in January of 1972,
and I'm facing taking
my doctoral exams
to qualify for the PhD program.
And I was taking all these hard,
dreary subjects to prepare.
And I wanted to do
one thing for fun.
And so I went and
knocked on Doc's door.
Didn't know him, but told him
about what I had been doing
and said, I really want to learn
how to do strobe photography.
Can I take your
undergraduate course?
And he said, sure,
we'll let anybody in.
[FF] "Anybody", even
you, right? [laughing]
[KV] Yeah.
Even me, right?
And so I took the
subject that spring,
which is called Strobe
Project Lab, which we still
teach today.
I was a grad student, and I
had had dozens of lab courses.
And so the lab work was a lark.
It was just fun.
And I just had a blast.
And he needed a TA
the following year,
and so hired me to be
his teaching assistant.
And that's when we really
got to know one another.
[FF] What a story.
A little like-- not
quite our story,
but I met you when I,
too, knocked on your door.
[KV] Same door.
[FF] Same door.
I said, I'd really like
to make science pictures.
And you said, we'll
take anybody. [laughing]
And at that point,
you were terrific.
You just said, yeah, let's
see what we could do.
And it expanded
through the years.
[KV] Well, and that's
the spirit of Doc
that I wanted to have in what
we call the Edgerton Center.
When Doc died in
January of 1990,
I proposed to MIT that,
as a legacy to Doc,
we turn his laboratory
into a place
where MIT students could
come knocking on the door
and get help to
be able to pursue
hands-on experiential projects
that they wanted to do.
And essentially, that
was the beginning.
And the Edgerton
Center was formally
founded in August of '92.
And no now we're
pushing 25 years.
[FF] That's right.
You might have a
celebration at some point.
[KV] Yeah.
We have to think about that.
So we're almost 25 years
old, and the initial vision
was to have it continue to
be a go-to place for know how
in high speed photography.
So we continue to
teach the subjects.
We continue to do a
professional development
course in the summer.
[FF] It's the go-to
place, no question.
[KV] We try to still do that.
But we also wanted to help
MIT students who had projects
that they wanted to work on
outside of the classroom.
And so today, the way that is
embodied in the Edgerton Center
is, we sponsor about a dozen
student clubs and teams that
build stuff-- so the
Solar Electric Vehicle
Team and Underwater Autonomous
Vehicle Team, Formula
SAE, Robotics, Aerial
Vehicles, a team
that rides coast to
coast called Spokes.
They ride bikes across the
country in the summertime,
stopping along the way
to teach middle school
lessons in science.
[FF] Oh, man.
I love that.
That's wonderful.
Let's turn to some
of Doc's pictures.
[KV] Alright.
[FF] And maybe if we can
concentrate on what have become
iconic, in a way.
This is your story.
We're looking at
books on the desk,
and Kim is going to look
with me at some images.
And I might ask some questions.
We'd like to teach
our students taking
our course-- we'd
like to introduce them
to some of the techniques.
We don't want to go too deeply,
because we're not actually
doing this in this course.
But I felt it was
important for them
to be aware of this kind of
photography for later on,
maybe.
[KV] Right.
I thought mostly
what I would talk
about today doesn't
actually have a lot to do
with high speed techniques.
It has more to do with why
was Doc a great photographer.
[FF] OK, great.
Let's go.
[KV] And that's
relevant to anybody
who's trying to take a picture.
So I'm going to do it a
little bit chronologically.
Doc was fascinated
with liquids and water
and taking pictures of those
things, for some reason,
very early on.
And he claims the
very first picture
that he took of that wasn't
of an electric motor.
And he was taking pictures
of electric motors
because that was his PhD
thesis, and he needed the strobe
to help him understand motors.
He claimed the first
picture that he
took using a flash,
of something else,
was water coming
out of a faucet.
And for the rest of his life,
he took pictures of water.
Water is tricky.
It's hard to take
pictures of it.
And then his iconic photograph
is the crown splash,
called "Coronet," the
splash of the milk drop.
And the original
black and white of it,
which we're looking
at right here,
was included in the first
ever photographic exposition
at the Museum of Modern Art.
And I guess before
that, they didn't
consider photography art.
But it's there.
It's in the collections.
And it was 1937.
So there's that picture,
and that's liquid again.
But really, an amazing
picture that nobody
had ever seen before.
Because really good stop motion
pictures hadn't existed before.
But actually, in
fact, that's a lie.
I went back recently
and did a little work,
because I helped with somebody
giving a talk in Cambridge.
And there's some pictures
of splashes of milk drops
that go back to about
the turn of the century.
[FF] I know.
[KV] And now I've forgotten
the name of the guy who did it.
Famous guy.
[FF] I wrote it down somewhere.
I just saw it at the
Victoria-- no, I'm sorry.
I saw it at the London-- it's
at the Science Museum in London.
[KV] That's right.
[FF] And I just
saw it a month ago.
I said, wait a second.
That's before Doc.
[KV] That's right.
So I think Doc had to have
known about those and seen them.
But the fellow
who had done them,
this was before good
electronic triggering.
And this is about all I'll say
about high speed photography--
the key to high
speed photography
is to have a very
short duration flash,
but to have a way of knowing
when to make it go off.
In the trade, we call
that "triggering".
How do you trigger the
flash to make it go off?
And the way you take a
bullet picture is you
use a microphone.
And when the shock wave from the
bullet passes the microphone,
the microphone
sets off the flash.
And in a darkened room,
you can look at where
the bullet is supposed to be.
You shoot the gun,
the flash goes off,
your eye sees it
exactly where it is.
And if you want your picture
to have the bullet three inches
to the left, you take
the microphone-- which
is down below, out
of sight-- move
it three inches to
the left, do it again,
and it's exactly
where you want it.
[FF] That's brilliant.
[KV] So triggering is a lot
of the story about high speed
once you have a source
of a high speed flash.
[FF] So you're actually
triggering the light.
[KV] Triggering the
timing and the light.
It takes two things-- good
timing and a very short
duration burst of light.
So one of the two
inventors of photography
was William Henry Fox Talbot.
And in 1859, he took
a flash picture.
So the first flash
photograph is 1859,
and it was an air gap spark
of a capacitor discharge.
And it was a piece of
newspaper spinning on a disc.
So flash photography
goes back a long way.
[FF] Do I remember correctly
that he tried it with water
and eventually decided to--
[KV] I honestly don't know.
My guess is he-- I'm sure he
tried it wither water first.
And in fact, my guess
is he saw it in water
and he said, oh, that is cool.
How can we really do it?
[FF] So is this just milk?
[KV] Yeah.
I know they used milk early on.
And of course, milk turns sour
in the lab in not very long.
And so pretty soon
after that, they
figured out how to
do it with fake milk,
so that it would last
a little bit longer.
So that picture, then,
was taken in the mid '30s.
And then when color
film came out,
then Doc took the
picture again in color.
And that's the iconic one in red
that's on postcards everywhere.
[FF] I sort of like
this one better myself.
[KV] I'll tell a lot of stories.
A couple of other
stories about Doc--
he knew he had a good
thing, but the world
didn't know he had a good thing.
And he went Kodak
and said, you ought
to make a product out of this
and sell cameras with flash
units, with electronic flash.
And at that time, people
were using flashbulbs.
And they said, well,
we looked into it.
We figured we could sell
about 50 units a year.
It just isn't worth it.
This is in the '40s.
And so Doc set out then
to prove them wrong
and to generate so much demand
that they couldn't ignore it.
And so he started building the
first portable units, battery
operated.
He equipped sports photographers
with portable units.
And so there's a picture
I didn't dig out today.
It's in the Boston Garden,
and it's an indoor track meet.
And it's a runner
coming around the curve.
And it's just absolutely crisp
stop motion shot of this guy.
And it was the first high
speed flash sports photograph
to go out on AP wire photo.
And then after that, there's
another fantastic image.
So Doc, he said, I'm
going to prove them wrong.
I'm going to show people that
this is the way to do it.
And the other picture that
I didn't pull out today
is the absolutely
classic sports shot,
which is the knockout
punch from Joe Lewis.
It's the Joe Lewis shot.
When that went out on AP, that
was a show-stopper picture.
OK.
There we go.
And that is the Chilean
Arturo Godoy in 1940.
[FF] Can you imagine
seeing something
like that for the first time?
Opening up a whole new world.
Very exciting.
[KV] So it didn't take, I think,
too many pictures like that.
[FF] No, that's all you need.
[KV] And the photography
industry started to say,
there's something
important here.
So then he got really
fascinated with speed.
And what would
impress people more
than to be able to stop
a bullet in flight?
I think that Doc said,
we got to do that.
And so he took lots
of bullet pictures.
So people know
pictures of bullets
through apples and
all sorts of things.
[FF] And people are
doing it in classes.
[KV] Yeah.
And we show our students
how to take a bullet
picture every year,
because it's just so cool.
But the picture that I
pulled out to talk about
is a picture that
has three balloons
in a row with a bullet
passing one after another
through the third.
And so the first one is in
almost complete disintegration.
The second one is
partially gone,
and the third one is
just barely showing
the effects of being shot.
This essentially, in
a single photograph
with a single flash of
light, does a wonderful job
of showing the passage of time.
So I think this is just a
brilliantly crafted photograph
to tell a story in
a single picture.
[FF] That's mind blowing.
[KV] He was really clever
at that kind of thing.
And they took lots
of bullet pictures,
but this is one of my
favorites, because it
was so cleverly done.
And this was before
the development
of high-speed,
multiple flash cameras.
So Doc's contribution to
high-speed photography
was the perfection
of two things.
The electronic
controls-- so now you
had transistors
and modern things
that you could switch
current very quickly--
and also, very short
duration sources of light,
and in particular,
the xenon flash
tube, which is in every
camera that you buy.
So he perfected the
xenon flash tube,
which gives out very bright,
daylight color spectrum light
in a very short duration.
[FF] Kim, around what year
are we talking about, roughly?
[KV] Well, there were
strobes available
when he was doing his
PhD work in the late--
he started about 1928.
Then these pictures,
like the one
in the Museum of Modern
Art, early and mid '30s,
by that time, I think
he was using Xenon.
He was developing flash
tube technology back then.
And I was a TA in
1972, one of the labs
that you did is
you went in the lab
and made your own flash tube.
Doc really understood
flash tube technology.
You had made your own.
And so we had Pyrex glass
and glass blowing setup.
And you took the
glass, and you learned
how to embed the
electrodes in it
to conduct the
electricity inside.
You filled it with xenon
at the right pressure,
and then you pinched it off,
and you had your own tube.
[FF] Talk about hands on.
[KV] Yeah.
[FF] That's what
he was all about.
[KV] When you took the
course in those days,
you tested flash tubes.
You made your own.
And you also then went and
took pictures of bullets,
and had to do a
project of your own.
It was called
Strobe Project Lab.
In the second half
of the course,
you had to choose something
of your own to do.
And so students, by that time,
had pushed multiple pianos
off the top of dorms and
taken pictures of them
and stuff like that.
But I was an ocean
engineer, and I
took on a project of taking
high speed technical photographs
for quantitative purposes of
propellers in a water tunnel.
Because propellers under certain
conditions generate bubbles,
and you may see this
helix going downstream,
and it's called cavitation.
The propeller cavitates,
it erodes it very fast
and damages it.
And if you're a
submarine, it makes
a horrendous amount of noise
and makes it easy to detect you.
So cavitation is important.
But pictures of things with
bubbles around them in water
are actually kind
of hard to take.
So we have a propeller tunnel
here in the Ocean Engineering
department, and they had
been taking pictures in it,
but they weren't very good.
And so I actually
took a lot of pictures
and then wrote the manual on how
to actually take good pictures.
[FF] Fantastic.
[KV] I think it's still
in the drawer over there.
Lighting is the
most critical part.
Bubbles reflect so much.
And the windows, you've got to
take pictures through windows,
which is a problem.
[FF] Major problem.
[KV] So you learn
all about how to take
the things that reflect on you,
and bubbles reflect like crazy.
So getting the lighting,
the exposure correct
is a tricky part.
[FF] Yeah.
We talk a lot about that.
[KV] Doc was an opportunist,
but he was also very creative.
Another thing that Doc did--
he was an MIT professor,
and to this day, high speed
photography's probably greatest
use is in industrial settings.
Doc soon was sought out
by people in industry
to use high speed
photography to troubleshoot.
All through his life,
he did lot of what
turned out to be really
interesting consulting jobs.
So he was always
carrying his camera.
And he would take
pictures of opportunities
when he thought they were
just really cool pictures.
And this is one of
my favorite ones.
This shows a mill
worker sometime in 1937.
This is the paper mill.
And paper mills are
notorious for-- have you ever
seen a newspaper being printed
or something like that?
The paper is streaming across
rollers at very high speed.
And if something goes wrong,
you get an enormous mess
in a hurry.
And it's going so fast.
The paper is moving so fast.
You can't see with your
eye what the problem is.
And so Doc's new high
speed photography
was a real blessing
for people in industry
with things that were very high
speed and could get in trouble.
But this is an example of that.
He was no doubt working
on a consulting job.
You can see in the background
these big rolls of paper that
are going through this mill.
He had probably been taking
very technical pictures,
probably trying to get them
to understand something.
And then he saw this fellow,
this worker, with a pitchfork
with this enormous
mass of trimmings
off the edges of a paper roll
forking this big-- like it's
hay, but it's not hay.
It's paper.
But it's a beautiful picture.
[FF] It's wonderful.
[KV] And so his sense of seeing
a good picture and saying,
I've got to do this, and
then his craftsmanship
of being able to make
it a great picture, not
just an ordinary picture.
[FF] What kind of camera
was he lugging around?
[KV] This was probably
a four by five.
He used a lot of four by five.
I've forgotten the term.
I haven't used one in so long.
[FF] Cassettes or--
[KV] Yeah.
With the back on it, and you
put it in and pull the slide out
and took you picture.
[FF] Which is
considerably cumbersome.
This is without a tripod?
[KV] My guess is-- I don't know.
He would also, then-- he
would just carry along
a 35-millimeter of what camera
was available at the time just
to be able to take setup
pictures and quick stuff.
But when he then really
wanted a good picture,
he'd get out the four by five,
and he'd put it on a tripod
if he had one there
and do it right.
And this is a big version of
this picture in the hallway
outside.
[outside Kim's office] You
were standing almost in front
of if out there.
[FF] Oh, OK.
[KV] So that's one of my
favorite Doc "opportunity"
kind of pictures that
came from his consulting.
So what's that?
Stonehenge.
[FF] Wow.
[KV] Yeah.
It's a "wow" picture
of Stonehenge
that was another opportunity.
He had to plan this
rather carefully.
Here's this sister picture
to this that's upstairs.
And if we go upstairs,
you can see it.
It's this dull looking,
why do you bother to put
that image on the wall picture.
But this photograph is taken
at midnight, thereabouts.
And the sister companion
picture that goes with it
is a photograph from a night
reconnaissance aircraft.
The pilots are practicing
for taking photographs using
brand new Edgerton strobe
equipment to take photographs
of Normandy in June of 1944.
So this is leading up to that.
They've installed these
brand new electronic means
of taking reconnaissance
photographs
and put them in US Army
Air Force airplanes
and are teaching
the pilots to do it.
Prior to the use
of flash, you would
have one plane fly over high
altitude-- like 5,000 or 10,000
feet-- and drop
flares on parachutes,
and then the
reconnaissance plane
would have to fly in at
1,500 feet illuminated,
backlit by the flares so that
people with guns could see it.
And so it was really
dangerous work.
And then you'd fly over with
the lights from the flares,
taking the pictures, but
also getting shot at.
So that had been
the standard way
to do reconnaissance
photographs.
The Army Air Force came to
him early in the war and said,
can we use your flash technology
to take pictures at nighttime?
And so they started developing
really powerful flashes.
So your typical
camera flash might
be five watt seconds of energy.
That's a measure
of electric power.
So five.
So by the end of the
war, Edgerton flash units
that were being carried
in reconnaissance aircraft
were 50,000 watt seconds.
[FF] I can't even imagine.
[KV] And one of the
movies about Doc
that shows him in a
classroom, and he's
got a yardstick with a sheet
of newspaper taped to it,
hanging from it, and he's
standing about as far from you
to here.
So the 50,000-watt second flash
unit has a reflector about this
big around, and a flash
tube with the xenon in it.
It's a coil, a helix
about this big around.
And you shoot it off, and
the piece of newspaper
would just burst into flames.
That's how much
heat is coming off
of this thing with the light.
So they were installing units.
They wanted to send the pilots
out to practice with it.
And he said, let's take
a picture of Stonehenge.
And so he was on the ground, and
he set his four by five camera
on a fence post, and he
knew when they were coming.
And he just opened
the shutter and waited
for the night reconnaissance.
[FF] Are you telling me the
light was coming from the--
[KV] The light comes
from the airplane.
[FF] And it traveled that far?
It was so strong.
[KV] Because the
airplane is trying
to take a picture of
what's on the ground.
So the photograph
that's upstairs
is the photograph of Stonehenge
taken by the aircraft.
So you can see the
aircraft photograph,
and this is the companion
photograph that goes with it.
[FF] That's an absolutely
fabulous story.
[KV] So taking photographs
of things in wartime
is pretty commonplace.
But knowing to be here with your
camera on the fencepost and get
this image that no one else
before or since has been able
to take...
[FF] That's absolutely fabulous.
[KV] So this just shows his
brilliance as a photographer.
So I really love that picture.
Then this is the more recent
typical bullet through apple
making applesauce.
Doc's comment was, it
takes a microsecond
to take the picture and
all morning to clean up.
And so I was his teaching
assistant in '73 -
'74 in this subject we
called Stobe Project Lab.
And he was exactly my age now
when I was working for him.
He had just retired,
and he was 69.
Retirement meant to him
that he got to keep his lab,
but he only had to do what
he wanted to do, basically.
He was so important MIT.
He said, look,
I'll tell you what.
I'll stop drawing salary,
but you let me keep my lab.
And they said fine.
And so he kept coming to
work every day until 1990.
So this was 1972.
So I had been in the
class in the spring.
In the summertime,
I'd talked to him
and found out he needed a TA.
I was a doctoral student
in ocean engineering.
In May of '72, I
did pass the exams.
And my one fun
thing for the term
had been taken the high
speed photography course.
And Doc and I agreed that
I'd be the TA in the fall.
So I showed up about
Labor Day, and there
was a letter waiting for me.
And the letter said, Doc says,
sorry I can't be there, Kim.
My mother's not feeling well.
And at the time I said--
he's 69 years old.
Your mother is not feeling well?
She was 98 or
something like that,
and he was off visiting
with her in Nebraska.
And he said, well,
I'd like you to think
about working on a project
while you're my TA.
That's kind of unusual.
TAs usually grade the lab
books and helps in the lab,
but you don't do some
research as well.
Doc says, why don't
you do a project?
And he says, I've never done
Color Schlieren photography.
Now, Schlieren
photography had already
been used for many, many
years in the aircraft industry
to take photographs of aircraft
models in supersonic speeds.
Because at supersonic
speeds, everybody
knows about sonic booms--
you have a shock wave
that comes off of the aircraft.
And a shock wave is a
high intensity sound wave.
In the aircraft industry, you
could study the shock waves
in a wind tunnel if you had
a photographic technique that
would make shock waves visible.
So it was called Schlieren, and
they did it in black and white.
And there were a few
color techniques.
But Doc says, so I've
done Schlieren before,
but I've ever done
color Schlieren.
Why don't you see
if you can do that?
So that was September.
I want to the library,
found four different ways
of doing Schlieren
photography in color,
all the technical journals.
Built my first setup,
took my first pictures.
And Doc has come back by now.
And I take them
in to him, and he
takes that his 10
power loop, which he
always carried with him.
And he holds the 35-millimeter
film up, and he looks at it
and he says, Van, it looks
a little out of focus to me.
And it wasn't because I
couldn't focus a camera.
But that's just the nature
of that particular method.
So then I went
back to the library
and built another system
and did it differently,
and walked in a couple
weeks later and showed Doc
the pictures.
And remember, this is color.
Black and white was
easy in Schlieren.
This was color.
So I walk in, and Van,
I don't like the color.
So you have to
understand that one
of the reasons it took so long
is you get the system set up,
you take some black
and white pictures just
to make sure it was looking OK.
Because you could take
three or four frames
of 35-millimeter
black and white film,
walk across to the photo lab,
develop it right on the spot,
and hold it up wet
to see what you got.
And if it looked right, then
you went back across the hall,
put the color film
on the camera,
took a whole roll of
pictures, and then set it off
and waited a week.
In 1972, you had to wait a week.
[FF] I remember those days.
It's called film.
[KV] Right.
It's film, and not
instant film, either.
And it took a week
to get them back.
So that was all
part of the process.
So it wasn't until
December or so-- I
was getting pretty frustrated,
and I found an article
in Scientific American.
And there was a
fellow by the name
of CL Stong, who for decades had
a column in Scientific American
called The Amateur Scientist.
And it was basically the
do-it-yourself science column
inside Scientific American.
And he would accept
contributions from people
and choose which ones he liked.
And each month, there'd be
another build your own radio
or do this or do that.
And there was an article on a
new way to do color Schlieren.
And it had been developed
by a graduate student
at the University
of Tennessee, a guy
by the name of Gary Settles.
And he hadn't done the high
speed photography part,
but he had come up with a
better way to do the color.
So I built that, and I took the
pictures, and I had three four
of them.
And I think one of the
earliest pictures I took
was very much like this one.
And I walked into Doc's
office one morning,
and I handed him this
35-millimeter color slide.
And he looks up, and he says,
Van, I think you've got it.
[FF] Oh my gosh.
Hallelujah.
You must have felt--
[KV] September, October,
November, December, January.
[FF] Whoa.
[KV] But then once we had
it-- once he saw a picture
like this, we knew we had it.
And so then he
just encouraged me
to take pictures of
everything under the sun.
And so we just tried
all sorts of stuff.
[FF] So we're
seeing-- am I right?
We're seeing changes
of index of refraction.
[KV] Yeah.
So color Schlieren allows
you to see changes in index
in a transparent medium--
so water, air, anything
that light will
pass through, you
can take a Schlieren
picture of it.
So this is a candle.
This is just the
ordinary hot air
above a candle, which
you normally can't see,
except it's a mirage effect,
like when you're looking down
a highway in the desert.
And this is a 22-caliber bullet,
and this is the shock wave
that accompanies it.
And the amazing thing about
shock waves is they make a V.
And the angle of the V-- one
over the sine of this angle
is the mach number.
So if that angle is 30
degrees, sine of 30 is 1/2.
1 over 1/2 is 2.
That bullet is traveling mach
2, or twice the speed of sound.
[FF] That's fabulous.
[KV] So in pictures
like this, there's
a lot of really interesting
physics and things
to talk about.
The color in this particular
Schlieren technique-- the color
you see tells you the
direction in which
the light was refracted.
So this is a little bubble,
just a ball of hot air.
It's hottest in the center,
it's cooling radially.
In all directions, the
temperatures are dropping.
So the index of refraction
is increasing radially
in all directions.
So if the light radios
into the upper part here,
the light bends toward
increasing index.
Up here, the light was bent up.
Here, it was bent to the right.
Here, it was bent to the left,
and in there, it was bent down.
So up is yellow, down is blue,
left is green, right is red.
[FF] So this is
highly informational.
[KV] Lots really
cool information.
[FF] Besides being
stunning to look at.
[KV] So then you
look at a picture
like this-- you can see
the candle flame nicely.
Now, that's itself illumination.
That light is coming
from the flame.
The light that took
the rest of the picture
is coming from your
high speed source, which
is 1/3 of a microsecond in
duration, which allows you
to stop a bullet in its tracks.
But the light to
get the candle flame
comes from the
candle flame itself.
But if you only had the shutter
open 1/3 of a microsecond,
that's not enough light
from a candle flame.
So in fact, the way you take
the picture is you turn off
all the lights in the
room, you open the shutter
on the camera for 1/4,
maybe 1/2 a second.
And when the person on the
gun hears the shutter click,
they pull the trigger.
The bullet travels
across the system.
The microphone is sitting
right here, by the way.
You can see the shock
wave right down here out
of sight as the microphone.
The shock wave hits
the microphone,
the microphones sets off the
flash, takes the picture.
So the flash is a third of
a microsecond in duration.
And that's the exposure time
for everything you see here.
But the shutter has been
open a half a second.
And so you have a
half a second exposure
time of the candle flame.
So they're always blurry,
because they flicker
when the shock wave goes by.
[FF] But he got
past that, right?
[KV] Oh yeah.
And that's a sparkler.
So if you knew what
you shutter time was,
your exposure time-- let's
say it was 1/8 of a second
or something, or maybe
less-- these little
trails are the sparks.
You could figure out
how fast they're going.
[FF] Oh gosh.
Of course.
[KV] So if you know
how long-- this is then
a time exposure of
the trail of a spark
as it travels through the air.
[FF] Like subatomic particles.
[KV] Yeah, in a way.
It's kind of like
a smoke chamber.
So actually, here's one
of my favorite pictures
of my own stuff.
And I'll talk about
both of these.
This is a picture
just of a soap bubble,
and it's just about life size.
And soap bubbles in
Schlieren systems
turn out to be
really interesting.
You see things you
don't normally see.
So this is a rubber hose.
It was dunked in
the soap solution,
and then you blow on the end
of the hose to make the bubble.
These are little streamers
of soapy solution
that are actually flowing on
the surface of the bubble.
And they do most
interesting things.
They go along, and then
they divide, and then
they divide again.
And a movie of this
is just fascinating.
In a picture like this,
if you look carefully,
you can actually see--
this is a shock wave,
but that's reflected
shock wave that
has actually hit the rubber
hose and bounced off.
And down here, there's an arc.
That's sound that's being
reflected off the bubble.
So bubbles are a lot of fun.
And then this picture
is fun in a sense
in that Doc took this
picture in another form
many, many years before.
So that's 1930s.
It's an old house fan,
and it's spinning.
And just above it
is artificial smoke.
It's basically chemical smoke.
And as the propeller
blade passes
by off the tip of any
surface, it's generating lift.
There's a vortex.
And he put the smoke there so
it gets sucked into the vortex
and shed downstream as a helix.
So in this picture,
you can see that vortex
forming in the smoke.
And this is the same
photograph with the same fan--
because he still had it around
the lab -- in Schlieren.
[FF] This picture has the fan.
The fan is--
[KV] This picture
is the whole fan.
This one-- this is
an alcohol lamp.
Usually, a little,
tiny blue flame.
This is just hot air.
The hot air is being
sucked into the vortex,
and then it is shed down.
Here's the helix.
It's this core vorticity
that goes off this way.
So there's another
one of the subjects
that we took pictures of.
So Schlieren photographs
were a lot of fun.
And then there's one
other bit of story
that is appropriate to,
of course, where you're
teaching grad students
and that sort of thing
about taking photographs.
This picture, Doc really liked.
And he said, OK, Kim.
He says, you need
to write a paper,
and then we're going to
go to this conference
and show your stuff.
Give this paper at the
11th International Congress
on High Speed Photography
in London in, I think,
the summer of 1973.
So I had this venue were
Doc was the grand old man.
He was the father of modern
high speed photography.
It was at University
College London.
They filled the auditorium.
And all these old cronies
that were friends of Doc
that he'd worked with through
the war and afterwards,
he was famous with these people.
So here I was under his wing,
getting to go everywhere he
went and treated like royalty.
So I gave them my
paper, showed 30 or 40
of these beautiful color images
that people hadn't seen before.
But he had also taken
about a dozen pictures, had
them enlarged to 16 by
20, sent them ahead,
and they'd all been
set up in a gallery.
So anybody coming
through the place
could walk through this gallery
and see all these photographs.
So while I was there,
this fella comes up to me
and he said, I really
like your photographs.
And he said, I'd
like to use them.
I said OK.
And so this picture was a cover
photograph on Nature Magazine.
[FF] Oh gosh.
[KV] So this was my first
professional publication
as a grad student.
It was a little short
article in Nature
with this photograph
on the cover.
[FF] What year?
[KV] '74.
There might be a copy of
it around here somewhere.
Talk about having--
[FF] I get it.
[KV] To have your first
publication when you're
applying as a
professor or something
somewhere, to be a cover
photograph in Nature,
that's a pretty
good place to start.
[FF] It's a pretty good
place to start. [laughing]
This is great.
Oh, Kim, thank you.
This is a wonderful,
wonderful story.
Not bad.
[KV] So that was my first
professional publication
as a graduate student.
And it was a nice thing to have
on my resume going forward.
I've said many times, I
wouldn't be here today
if I hadn't had that
experience with Doc Edgerton.
Even though I was
an ocean engineer
and I didn't continue
professionally
in high speed photography
as his mentee, what
it did for me is the year I
worked for him as a teaching
assistant was a
year I was not doing
something in ocean engineering.
And that was because I
hadn't found a thesis
topic that I really liked.
And it gave me a
year of extra time
that I could go do
something fantastically fun
and find a good thesis topic.
So by the end of
that year, I not only
got to give this paper, but I
had come up with a super thesis
topic, which then that opened
the doorways for me to becoming
a professor of
ocean engineering.
[FF] Timing.
[KV] Timing, a little luck.
And not being afraid
to knock on the door.
[FF] There you go.
Thank you.
Exactly.
Good job, Kim.
[KV] Yeah.
Thank you.